hey slugs welcome to a new episode um
today stay tuned so you can find out who
my new celebrity look-alike is it's not
rachel lee cook i'll tell you that
it's really not and it's not female
it's an it wait i don't think that's
appropriate um you guys i'm coming to
salt lake city wise guys comedy club
january 14th and 15th and i'm coming to
austin cap city february 24th and 26th
get tickets at estheronics.com and also
sleepoverbyaster.com is my clothing line
tune in stay tuned you're going to like
it um you can see me at bananas comedy
club in new jersey december 16th through
18th i will be at the
milwaukee improv the january 21st
through 27th i'll be in naples florida
at off the hook january 25th and 26th i
will be in tampa florida january 27th
and 30th and i'll be in blue room
february 5th 4th through 5th and there's
a lot more i'm going to be in dc i'll be
in austin we had to move those dates in
the summer please check out my website
andyletterman.com
shows and all the infos there
[Music]
wait i just am so happy you got these
glasses
it's my dream to have a twin like the
fact that your dependency twin like
people are afraid of me i will say that
i don't hate it but
but people do when they when they dress
like me they do go think i'm gonna care
and i am a twin through and through i'm
so happy to be twins with people that is
where i think our because in our venn
diagram like there's so much that's
different about our vendetta van dyke
but the middle the tiny sliver in the
middle where we have crossover it's like
we wish we were twins together
or which one's with everyone i'm gonna
say it here and hollywood we know you're
watching oh no esther and i need to be
in the remake of twins with she plays
obviously danny devito and i play
arnold schwarzenegger but there needs to
be a female reboot of that and you know
that would [ __ ] kill like i'm not
kidding at all i that i need to see that
movie so i can let's oh my god we'll do
that on our sleepover that'll be one of
our okay i'm wondering how much actual
genetics you guys share because do you
know that we share like 97 percent of
the same genes as a sea urchin really
like humans and sea urchins then we
definitely are related but i feel like i
can see it in myself yeah esther is
definitely at least 75 sea urchin
jacket by the way this was as a joke i
was gonna come in yesterday wearing a
puffy jacket like i was she's like i was
um
[Music]
like i was uh here oh okay i thought
because i have a new style icon who is
it
steve bannon
[Laughter]
i and i feel like it's okay to laugh
because it's like didn't he get arrested
it's like the party's over but like
steve i'm coming for you i have his
mustache i understand
a nice light one tell me i don't look
like this man i he i think he had the
same smile
okay that actually offended me
no i think there's something there i
think he's got look
um
he's got if anything he's got a cute
smile do you have any can you pull
pictures of him when like close to when
he was being arrested would you say when
he was young and hot
no he does look like philip seymour
hoffman would look now if we pulled him
up if we dug him up
a little extra bloat bloat wait so he
does he famously wear a lot of layers is
that a thing
yeah he always wears multiple button-up
shirts but esther you're missing the the
spray tan
oh i think it's for me it's going to be
fashion only okay so i'm not trying to
be like him in any other way so you're
not saying you guys even look like a
facially no it's a face okay
i gotta tell you that hair he looks
great
it's feathered i am attracted to him
hey there
he knew he was going to get arrested so
he got the spray tan got the hair cut he
got everything but it's like
it's a big offer pr opportunity
i feel like steve bannon has a big deck
oh hmm
i'd have to see the fact that i have to
see his pecs because pecks um correlate
to um dick size
the more concave the bigger the dick are
you serious actually oh my god wait a
second yeah my friend mike growing up my
candle same birthday what's up he's
older than me he um
he had this concave chest and he had a
huge dick
oh my god like us
although there is this is wholesome in
the sense that there's a hole in the big
dick's chest
it's whole song there's another hole
involved as well but i'm gonna really
attempt for this whole sum10 this time
because i feel like we really so my
question my proposition for wholesome 10
this morning is which disney character
do you relate to the least i relate to
the most the dick drawn in the clouds
the little mermaid
all the subliminal messages
we're never gonna do a wholesome test
it's we just have to deal with the fact
that our numbers will never be what they
could be because it's not who we are
answer my question esther here's your
shot okay at least relate to
i think so hard cause she does look like
the teapot
i feel like i'm not like gaston but as i
say that i'm like actually i am like
guest on
i think you are gaston was your guest on
your own podcast
never quite feel like you'd belong
i could always lose you
the most you'd have to be chip
the mom oh your chip that's who i am the
most
in in that um
beauty and the beast world chip chipped
[Laughter]
i wanna
oh look how cute oh sir come on it's
actually too good for you and i did have
a tea set of this and i loved it it was
a little chipped cup did you throw chip
on the floor
no no it came chip i had chipped i had
chipped stuff as a kid an anger
management
that's what i always say i love a guy
with a chocolate chip on his on his
shoulder
i love ex fat boys oh me too oh i like
yeah that's a good line what are you
talking can you what's up so fat boys
are my type i've been with fat boys for
um
like my last couple boyfriends have been
either currently fat or
um ex fat boys okay
and that's just not you're an ex ex-pat
means ex fat i love that yeah
not an ex fat ex fat come here baby wait
so
is this i'm is there like a skin
it's a hot boy's i mean sorry it's a fat
boy's gone hot uh mentality where it's
like they are now hot but they're still
hanging on to but their personalities
really very they're giving they're no
yes
yes it's true yeah no i was gonna say
there's a character down there i dated a
big guy who was the meanest person
and your and esther's biggest gift she
gave me was telling me he was on
taskrabbit
no there's nothing wrong with me i'm i'm
on taskrabbit check me out nothing wrong
with it the closest i ever came to china
i know i was like a rabbit you're
certainly not the tag oh actually you
are a task
the closest i ever came to
possibly cheating on bobby was the
taskrabbit guy and by me
wait yeah does carlos do taskrabbit was
that you're gonna say no was his name
angel
no because we dave and i always talk
about how
dave like has no like
skills and it's like you know you like
the man is supposed to like take care of
things but dave literally hires a guy
named angel on taskrabbit to hire to
like hang frames in our house is he cute
dave said dave only dave has met him and
dave says he's really hot he's kept him
from you did dave say really hot
i think he dave's like he's hot oh i
love dave dave is too good for you i'm
sorry i'm just gonna stay in here
yeah but he was very attractive and he
did a lot of things that usually i can
put things together myself but not this
particular thing come here randy was it
an orgasm
but by cheating i mean like i just you
know what i mean looked at him assemble
something like that and you were like
you were just stopping what you were
like now i'm gonna need you to clean up
the upholstery yeah do you think a new
task rabbit
was he like do you think he was like
putting on a show for you because you're
actually like pretty hot
well what turned me off afterwards was
that he was like hey like i watch you
guys on tiger belly and i was like oh no
there is something where it's like once
you know except i did bang one guy
i probably shouldn't say this give
it will never happen again one guy he
was so hot i literally could not not
[ __ ] him wait but he knew who you were
he knew who i was he was in the audience
i think that's fine but i would never do
it again but it was like i couldn't and
he didn't go like i hit on him from
stage as a joke and then he was from new
zealand on top of it
he was just so good-looking and then he
just kept dming because he was only in
town for like a week yeah and i just
i finally caved i couldn't help it
but we had a good night but it was
because i gave we had a lot of special
okay
oh we had a night yeah what does um sex
on k feel like i've never i've never
successfully done it
i've never completed you've never
successfully cooled actually no maybe
with my ex i did i just don't remember i
my ex and i did have really good sex so
i don't it never it didn't vary that
much when we're on drugs randy come here
come here my boy give me my boy i love
this he doesn't like when i talk about
sex with others he thinks of his father
randy come here i had to bring randy can
i tell you guys why i was i was ten
minutes wait does he think of his father
like the actual dog that is his
biological father no we don't speak of
that mexican is his name craig it's
craig his brother okay tell us why okay
so
i gotta call a text at 11 30 where he's
like all right i'm ready to i'm gonna
leave um
how's your spot at the store i'm like
your car is gonna be locked up and of
course he calls me car's completely
locked up he's drunk on hollywood
boulevard todd yes last night yeah i had
to go get him i guess he wasn't drunk
but he he
was on the street he was like this is
scary
he's like please pick me up of course i
ran into two little people that are fans
of the podcast what's up guys um so i
was like todd i'm busy i was like
facetime i was like look
we're hanging out sorry they're these
two little guys and they're they're i
don't call little people but and then
they have um this big like bodybuilder
with them than they do internet videos
but um
i was like todd you're gonna have to
stay on the street
so finally i get over i pick him up we
come home this morning i have to go
drive him and there's traffic so i have
to drive him to dave and buster's to get
his car we have randy with us because we
didn't have time to like walk randy to
pee or anything so bring randy we're
getting there it's it's it's starting to
like i realize i'm gonna be late for my
own job
and so i just started playing uh shallow
because
he was bradley cooper in my career
you're literally ruining my career todd
you're damaging my career and if you're
not hanging in a
garage you don't get it i broke up with
a boy at dave and busters you did
oh he didn't make you dave and bust he
didn't
oh he was such a hot boy too but um
he forgot his wallet when we had to pay
and dave and buster's can really rack up
yes
i didn't get to stay and play skee-ball
or anything he balls the best wait i
want to go i never let's go to dave i've
never gotten to go before i've never had
friends well i feel like my parents knew
you wouldn't like it no my parents
didn't take me anywhere fun for kids
because they didn't care
i did chuck e cheese when i was little
oh that's that's not it and my dad still
talks about how like it was the worst
place he's ever been and he had to sit
in the car
[Laughter]
we could go to dave and busters david
buster's is fun okay yeah yeah it's a
great place to break up with a guy i
would go with you guys i just i didn't
get to have any fun but there was a
comedy show we were like in the middle
of eating wings and it was like
announcement there's a comedy show in
room three or whatever and i was like oh
my god and i walked over and i was like
they're like do you want to do the show
and i was like no i have to go
but um i just i'm glad i'm over that
place in my career of doing random
restaurant yeah wait you guys did that
and earlier in your career like they've
been changing i have performed in a
laundromat yeah laundry mat sounds like
that's the only time she's actually been
near laundry too
that kind of sounds like cool and like
hipstery okay what about like a pizza
place where people are just trying to
have their dinner with an ambush
i went to a corporate gig with bobby
where it was someone's birthday um in
bakersfield and so it was like this
really rich guy who was like a farmer
and he just wanted a comedy section of
the party there was like hundreds of
people there and bobby it was like they
offered him a bunch of money and
it
i was mortified i was mortified for him
just even like watching him like no
one's listening everyone's like you know
socializing
if it's not a comedy club that's like a
building built for what you do you're
lowering or with your name on the
[ __ ] marquee like it's just it's the
worst i felt so bad for him not only did
i do ambush shows back in the day i
produced a few
you don't say
some someone even wondered did you
invent them i i said are you guys
enjoying things can i interrupt
uh i like interrupting with jokes but i
do feel bad when someone loses the
thought i go oh that is so [ __ ] up
you know i have to say though do you
guys follow what's an ambush show that's
why you call it when it's like people
are just enjoying their night it would
be like if you were in a restaurant and
all of a sudden they're like and now the
comedy show is starting oh god
like what like you're just eating your
pizza and there's nothing you can do and
it's bad
wait and the comedians are talking about
like masturbation and stuff and they're
mad at you and they're mad at you for
not liking them yeah projecting all of
their like anger at their parents on you
they start yelling oh is the soup good
well why don't i jizz in it and you're
like i'm just eating that's truly like
the first five years of our career yes
i had one called living it up at life
cafe at the restaurant i worked at
and it was
pretty rough but
i built a thing and then i brought it to
another place and that place was cool
but it was really people would be like
begging to do i'm like are you sure you
really want to do this it's not good
and it'll be like my customers like i
would try to like come back so some
people would come to see it and then
other people would just be livid
just their whole they're on a date or
they're like with their family
speaking of dates who are you guys on a
first date
what are you hiding who are you esther
how do you present i can't even imagine
how to present to myself on a first date
because there's like
i like i don't know i think i just no
one's ever asked to
i think i'd have to just be fully like
hi i'm i'm broken i have demons that are
coming out at the seams of
my skin have them or are them
i have demons and you are that you are
the demon what about you i've never been
on a first date ever bobby was my very
first first date
and it was like where'd you guys come
eating at coffee where'd you meet um we
met at a coffee shop i don't because
when i um
see a guy that i'm interested in either
at a bar or in like a public setting i'd
be like hey my friends and i are all
having drinks at this place and i stage
uh friend's nights right so you're just
so i'm safe kalyla i love that you stage
things that is like totally my what has
always been my like dating being fake
yeah yeah like staging like a like hey
you have to like manipulate and maneuver
like my first date with dave
because everything i've ever thought of
it was true yeah totally no we before
you came in and we were talking about
how i'm a dog
and like i sent i'm like always sensing
things oh i thought she went because
you're ugly
you drink out of a bowl
like i'm paying attention and i'm
sniffing everything at all you really
are but it's fun because you're doing it
in a chiller way now with the no i'm
always you've never been chill like
you're thinking your chill is
what did you stage for dave
i we went to my stand-up show and
i could tell i just first date was
stand-up show listen just hear me out so
we walk in and it was a laugh factory
and it was like half full
and i just in my mind i could just hear
all the stories i've heard from benji
where he took a girl on a first date and
bombed and then like the date was over
and i was like don't do it don't do it
and i was like you know what it's really
light in there tonight let's just go to
let's just go get a coffee and he was
like okay
and later dave was like
he was like oh i thought that was cool
you just don't perform if you don't want
to and i was like yeah
oh my god that's so funny remember when
we were cancellers oh yeah i used to oh
yeah we made a we made a pact and no
longer canceled we had to really make a
commitment well you know i did a thing
that changed my life i'm not kidding you
guys like i forgot if it was 2019 or
2018 but it was me and my college
friends and we all did this thing it was
like i think we called it like no
canceling 2019 or whatever and we had
this policy that if you ever said yes to
a plan with anyone in your life for that
whole year and you canceled it you had
to do a punishment and our punishment
was like my friend who lives in santa
monica and i live you know another side
of town you have to like in rush hour
and meet for coffee which is so annoying
or like do an airport pick up that's how
i feel every time i have to come here by
the way so
after i did that one year of not
canceling i pretty much never cancel
anything anymore that's how much esther
hates driving
my my feelings just fluctuate so much
where it's like when i'm on a a high
it's like i'll make i'll make all sorts
of coffee dates yeah and then just it
just so happens that like the
coincidence is always this on the day of
i don't know what happens to me but it's
like i want to kill myself yeah forever
even considering making a plan with that
particular person why did i do this yeah
you run and you're like running with the
moment and how you feel and
you want to be nice yeah yeah so you do
it but i don't do it any i don't do that
but in that moment because i genuinely
want to meet
and then on the day of i genuinely don't
want to it's just come to us guys our
podcast is a hit we no longer come to
you
one thing that has become very important
to me is looking
really cool and fly in my outfit when
did you when did you start
i know you're joking but it's gotten a
lot better since citrix
okay but honestly you guys know that
feeling when you stumble upon a piece of
clothing that is just so
perfect for you that you don't even know
you needed it but now you're like i
can't live without this that is how you
feel when you use stitch fix freestyle
and you know what if you don't feel that
way you just send it back your style
isn't one size fits all it's about what
suits your body and what suits the
moment so why not shop at a store that
is
actually personalized to your size and
style and that's why we're introducing
stitch fix freestyle a shop that is
built just for you stitch fix freestyle
is your trusted style destination where
you can discover and instantly buy
curated items based on your style likes
and lifestyle whether you're looking for
a brand you love or to try a new one at
stitch fix freestyle you can shop a
range of over a thousand brands
personalized to your size and fit and
with styles for workouts to work wear
for lounging around the house or for a
night out on the town stitch fix
freestyle has clothes for any occasion
plus
my favorite part there's no subscription
required and they offer free shipping
returns and exchanges get started today
by filling out your style quiz at
stitchfix.com
tuesday that's stitchfix.com tuesday to
try stitchfix freestyle that's
stitchfix.com
tuesday
growing up cereal was actually like the
greatest memory of all time honestly
when your parents would let you eat
cereal for dinner wasn't it awesome even
though if you think about it now it's
like your parents were just being the
most lazy
we were doing them a favor yes but
honestly cereal that we ate as a kid is
so bad for you and it's just junk that i
i don't want to have it anywhere near me
and that is why magic spoon has solved
all my problems magic spoon has zero
grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams of protein
and only four net grams of carbs in each
serving only 140 calories a serving is
such a light dinner i know and it's keto
friendly gluten free grain free soy free
and low carb plus you can build your own
box and the available flavors to build
your very own custom bundle or cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter blueberry
cinnamon cookies and cream and maple
waffle you know what i do because i'm so
healthy these days i do fruity and
blueberry double the fruit boom it's a
fruit salad look at that at a fruit
salad for breakfast honestly than me
every time i hear the about the fruity
flavor of magic spoon it's like i can't
rest until i go home and have a bowl
it's so good you guys can go to
magicspoon.com
tuesday to grab a custom bundle of
cereal and try it today and be sure to
use our promo code tuesday at checkout
to save five dollars off your order and
now with esther's new recreational fun
she really enjoys this cereal that's so
good and then you don't feel as guilty
because it's healthy
and magic spoon is so confident in their
product it's backed with a 100 happiness
guarantee
so if you don't like it for any reason
they'll refund your money no questions
asked so remember get your new delicious
bowl of guilt-free cereal at
magicspoon.com tuesday and use the code
tuesday to save five dollars off thank
you magic spoon for sponsoring this
episode and my dinner later
but i've gotten really good at just
straight up saying i cannot come or i
don't want to come um i don't want to
meet without giving an explanation i
love that about you it's like it's just
it's not my day i only want people like
that in my life because the worst thing
to me would be if i'm hanging out with
someone and they don't want to be there
oh my god our entire friendship honestly
set you up set up i was never i wasn't
even joking
i've been dead serious
um i've been on
i would break up with a guy because
dates like when you're a comedian you
meet people it's like you're just
already in a social
situation do you have them choose the
place or do you always call the shots
well i i only had two dates there were
online dates one
i met this guy at a bar in new york
and
then he picked the restaurant this was
the guy with the hand that was like
lobstery and then he took me to a
lobster
it was crazy
i was like i gotta do a joke i'm sorry i
wasn't gonna do a joke until this
but um
did you he forced my claw
um wait did you do a joke on the date no
oh okay i thought that okay but
certainly a lot of times after
[Laughter]
he that was one and then another one was
this guy i met online and
i had never done online dating so i
thought like you would just be attracted
to people that look like you would be
attracted to them in a picture i just
forgot about like pheromones and
people's cadence voice everything
and i so i went so hard i thought i was
gonna i was like
oh i'll like bang this guy i'm like
you're so hot i'm like ice bucket
challenged me with your jizz like i was
like so aggressive i was like lazy like
a donut i don't know what i just didn't
know how to like internet date
an ice bucket challenge reference but
make it sexual thank you
if you didn't do that you weren't on
twitter
during the whole thing oh my god that
was quite we should we should bring the
ice bucket challenge
where can we collect that much [ __ ]
though we need to do a cup ice bucket
after no nut november we should just
have pete and george like nut into a
bucket for like a whole six months oh my
god
they are people and whoever doesn't eat
spiders gets nut dumped on their hands
literally [ __ ] you [ __ ] can i tell you
something about spiders do you know that
spiders are afraid of spiders
so maybe you're a spider
you're a [ __ ] spider why are they
afraid of each other spiders have
arachnophobia they why how why
i don't know it's just the same way
humans are afraid of certain humans
like me and annie
okay so go ahead annie so i like meet up
with him and immediately he's disgusting
i mean he is the least attractive person
how so he's just gay voice like just not
hot like all of his pictures i was like
he said he worked in music i assumed it
was hip-hop
i got to his place his bike was on the
wall he's like he might as well be
wearing a bike helmet he had like raw
cashews as a snack i was like
wait that's funny it was just like but
you know what i mean you're disconnected
it's like on the nose or something like
just raw cashews it was just like well
cashews are sweet so they don't
necessarily need to be flavored it's a
big import um nut from the philippines
it just feels very like
thought out and like calculated yeah but
it's just like he was a loser it was
just like he was a [ __ ] loser can i
interject that you saying that just now
about the online like the pictures and
stuff it made me really it really sealed
for me that i could absolutely never
be on a dating app because i could never
get swiped on
here's something that hinge did here's
something that hinge did i think is
groundbreaking
for everybody
you can leave on in your bio a little
voice note
of a voice intro who you are like
there's this guy on tik tok he left a
little his voice note on his bio is you
know this is how i eat [ __ ] and then he
makes a sound but his when i look at his
picture i was like what have i swiped on
him and i'm like nope i wouldn't have
but then he when i listened to it it was
so funny and he was hot
i was like i would have absolutely
gone on a date with it's so funny
because he has to eat the girls out like
yeah like you can't like
but i just felt like and this was the
last time i felt this way this was the
way i felt a lot through like my 20s a
lot of the reason i drank was i always
felt like if i like
said i was gonna [ __ ] someone or alluded
to it or like what like i couldn't
handle like rejecting them so i would
literally sell myself out
and like get wasted so i could like just
like starfish and they could [ __ ] me and
hopefully we'd all forget that it
happened
but it was like i did that so many times
i would like choose the comfort of
strangers or like these guys i barely
know over myself
and this was the last time
i did that and i ended up going so i
what's one more round gonna hurt you i
know you though i know it'll be
disappointing we just all go and pretend
first dates let's ask permission from
our partners it's just for to pull it's
like i i like it
i just
it's well i would it would be much
easier for me to talk about what
what would i want a first date to be
like i like i don't know why am i saying
that but here well let's let's offer one
day
gone hinge
choose one person
cancelled by every guy like every guy's
like these three cheating bobby doesn't
give a [ __ ] we should call this the new
cheaters
and then
we kind of take inventory or committed
change of who we are in those first
dates who we what we don't want to say
about ourselves
you know what we do say about ourselves
this is so interesting i have no because
i have no idea what i would do i would
love to know
yeah i want to know too i actually had a
date with that musician that was kind of
fun we like went to church we went to oh
that's right
that's cute it was fun we had a good
time it was and it made me like like him
even though not like romantically but i
like i'm always like i like that guy
even though he did text me too long i
was like why are you still texting me
you don't like me i would want to have
like an activity that's like really
random like that like that sounds funny
we had a whole day i went to tj maxx he
was like holding my jacket while i was
trying stuff on and stuff it was fun
dad's like put this on try that i think
i saw um kristen stewart on um maybe an
early date with her ex because they were
a marshalls and they seemed like they
were having a blast
yeah cute i remember jules and i were
like oh my god how cute is it that
they're here and i'm buying sports bras
because they're super cheap marshalls i
definitely wouldn't want anything like
work related because i do feel like
that's a cheesy move that hollywood guys
make where they're like
oh we'll go to this taping or like like
oh i can show you this like i don't know
anything work-related where it's like
bragging about yourself yeah i want to
see this i want to see both of you on a
first date with someone who absolutely
does not know who you are what if we
fall in love
like what are you like what is this
billy we sign a contract with our
partners where it's like what if we just
called this triple x's and we just
themed it about our experts what if we
call this hot holes
oh esther something happened in space
that i feel like you'd very deeply
relate to okay i'm listening where can i
guess yeah did a monkey uh
drown in its own pits close
kalila i do feel like we are not as
connected as we used to be oh my god
that's so dramatic i just wanted to see
where you're going
all right we're good guys i just wanted
to check
you just have to you got to catch them
off guard make sure they still like you
you know what's funny is i literally
walked in the space said
i just can't wait to get [ __ ] up with
you esther honestly i think vegas is
going to be the best place wandering
around vegas with you incredibly high
will be more fun than i'll get high then
you will yeah yeah
yeah
wait can we get this on the books
december who's that what's up okay
george i'd like to circle back to um
what happened in space that i feel like
it's primed for
i think it's a dream come true the
monkey um drowning in its own piss is
not very far
annie okay yeah i know my girl yeah
something happened in the spacex capsule
where their um bathrooms are all broken
so now um they're gonna return uh-huh
they've just had to use
diapers
oh my god dude i want to go to space
that's perfect for that astronaut [ __ ]
that that wore the diaper and did the
drink exactly how happy would she be
though imagine the announcement in space
she's an astronaut
and i'm just sitting there well where do
you think they got the diapers she's the
one that brought them with her one eye
she broke the toilet
[Laughter]
on purpose i'm like oh wait what oh did
you guys see the toilets are broken
i i have got the diapers i like the idea
that you have those glass sunglasses on
in space wait did decisive shits
correlate to the person's body size like
is my poo bigger than your poo your
[ __ ] might be in charge of some of
that bobby and i talk about this
literally for 300 episodes of tiger
belly we can't come together we got to
call brad williams he's the only one
that can tell us
no you guys these guys last night can we
ask him how big of a [ __ ]
these guys last night are so awesome i
almost was like will you crash my
podcast while they will be returning
in diapers i wonder like how do you feel
like a badass space guy when you come
back and everyone in the world knows
that you're wearing a diaper and it's
probably full
is this supposed to be how do you use
are you now you don't think diapers are
cool no i like to make a choice i love
diapers i think diapers are are you crow
diaper are you anti-diabetic i am pro
but i'm just saying there's a lot of
like macho men out there can we sell
diapers
annie wait we haven't even done our
three-person underwear our two-person
underwear we're going to throw oh did
you give it back to me oh wait what are
you i got that for your birthday
for your birthday she got you trying to
show person underwear oh
i'm good pete
today is the day pete's like i'll get
somebody didn't scrub
no i did take a bath this morning
a good old morning bath i can't imagine
waking up and taking a bath well
speaking of like the three-person
underwear i think two bears is kind of
biting our style here what oh let's see
boys down so uh it's a long bit uh so i
cut out just uh to the main part where
uh tom
left
uh with a uh a butt plug a vibrating
butt plug blood plug in his butt did you
get it in
oh he's putting did you get it in oh
wait i want to put mine in this is like
us i love it yeah
i know we should get things where we can
control them in each other kalila you
haven't missed anything it's just bert
has been like oh my god you're putting
it in you're putting it in
and then he's sitting down i don't think
you're supposed to sit are you serious
all right i'm gonna go put mine in
we would have put it in on camera on
each other yeah tom looks so happy
god it's so weird that there's no chicks
here
i feel like we should have offered to
put it up there butts
i'm going to call leanne and ask to see
if yeah call the wives let's go through
the wives and how are you sitting down
is it is it making it go further with
you sitting can we not even tell the
guys what we want to do and just
coordinate with the wives i think so
yeah it's just different objects we
shove up their ass what if the wives
were like
what if the wives are like okay annie
and esther yes but kalila cannot go
under my husband we can't
it's already been an issue
i um i'll give christina p a list of um
objects that she pre-approves
oh my gosh and then funny will as a
nurse she'll insert yeah yeah i'm just
i'm doing it as a podcaster not as a
woman
correct it's my job it's a very two very
different things there's a very big
distinction there i'm a professional
remember how excited kalila got when i
said we weren't friends she goes what do
you mean
oh we're best friends
you guys aren't wrong by the way i also
have like seasonal effective
a season seasonal depression you know
what carries that what annie letterman
facetime baby hawaii's gonna cure this i
am so certain that
i'm working with an insane person and
i'm rocking because i'm so happy about
it okay
esther's hard work by the way right here
she's got her heel up her [ __ ] crotch
she's that girl did you guys have that
girl in class no yes i rocked on her
heel oh more than that she was always so
stimulating yes like this and then she i
so i initially i went to an
international school but i moved to an
all-girls catholic school called stc
after called esther
and there was a girl there she would
constantly be suspended because she
could not stop
yes that was like her like tourette's
tick was yes that was and she would use
rulers she would just always be doing
this maybe that's what louie has i
really don't want to have a daughter i
feel like
how embarrassed i would be you would
have so much in common so proud of her
um
so what do we want out of um tom and
burt because i have a dream of doing a
bdsm episode with bert because i feel
like he's really adventurous yeah and so
i'd like to extend the invite out to our
dear friend what hasn't been done to his
balls already that's really the question
well we're gonna have to ask him and
find out and we're gonna do that thing i
would like i did do the shot caller on
my i'm down to do some fun pranky things
too should like kalila like wax their
[ __ ] definitely oh yeah my hard wax
is a very very good you have to make
sure you go around the hemorrhoid
don't pull it out further you know maybe
that's okay
if you do that and it just pulls out
like
yeah it's just it's like a it's like a
clown with the
nap with the handkerchiefs but it's just
my intestines pre-arrange it with the
wives that it's a as the a christmas
gift you're gonna wax their [ __ ] it's
a christmas gift to the wife
and so they don't know what's happening
until they get there
yes she might not know it's us too what
if we like we we pretend it's like a spa
or something yeah
we should wear those early 1920s
pandemic masks you know that looks so
good oh my god those are so scary with
the duck bill and everything no
have you seen those they're so scary
it's really scary i can't imagine it's
worse than what i'm looking at
well-played
i have a question for you guys um oh boy
so get ready to take a nap guys i can't
wait to have this question i
am in a weird position where you guys
know this uh my i'm
my dad's only child and
and you're you're engaged to a man but
you're attracted to women no
what should you do
i am my dad's only child and he was an
only child and so
when his mom died his parents died
before i was born and when and i was
raised in their house the bullet didn't
they
and when you were raised in their house
yeah so when my grandmother passed away
my dad was like i'm in my 40s i'm never
going to have kids
i'm never going to get married and he
gave all of her stuff away like every
last inch of her jewelry her clothes
everything was given to a break-in so
here's my question i've heard that
there's a really nice watch i think it's
a rolex
and i know who ha who he gave it to oh
it's a family member
a distant family member he gave it all
to family members but all of them have
since like passed away so like i don't
know where everything is lost but
there's one thing that i know is with
someone who's still alive we don't have
that close of a relationship she's rich
as [ __ ] like she's way like this
relative is distant and she's got money
so it's not like a money thing here's
what you have wrong about rich people
they're greedy they'll never they'll
never give away because also the rich
thing they can buy anything they want
but you can't buy sentimental eyes right
but i'm like this isn't sentimental for
you it's not your grandmother like i'm
i'm just like wait here's my dad wait my
question is did your dad give the rolex
away or did he lose it gambling no he
that's a good question
why would you why would a gambler give
away a rolex because i think he i think
he plopped it on a table no the thing is
because he said that they all all the
people helped take care of her so he
gave all the her stuff to them so i was
like should i ask this woman for the
watch back you're gonna have to take
care of her
warby parker was founded with a
rebellious spirit and a lofty goal to
create boutique quality eyewear at a
revolutionary price point and when i
tell you that is not a lie
i'm addicted to their products because
i'll i'll get into it but they're so
affordable offering eyeglasses
sunglasses contact lenses and eye exams
warby parker is committed to providing
exceptional vision care online and in
stores their customer service is so good
by the way it really is amazing when you
call them
you know how you call places like hello
1-800 they're like hello warby parker
i'm like oh my god it's a person like i
wait do you want to know my favorite
thing about this and this is going to
make so much sense i they have wide
versions of all the glasses
my head is not meant for
things of this earth don't let your fsa
or hsa dollars go to waste put them to
good use on warby parker prescription
glasses prescription sunglasses which
are absolutely you need prescription
sunglasses contact lenses and eye exams
warby parker is committed to providing
exceptional vision care online and in
stores offering eyeglasses sunglasses
eye exams and contact lenses classes
start at 95 including prescription
lenses i mean that's unbelievable and
they're actually good quality like
and they're not yeah they're they're
like lightweight they're nice it's just
they're good so you guys can do what i
just did this week what i'm doing right
now which is try warby parker's free
home try on program where you order five
pairs of glasses to try at home for free
for five days there's no obligation to
buy and they ship free and includes a
prepaid return shipping label you can
try five pairs of glasses at home for
free at warbyparker.com tuesday and i
want to say i did this literally eight
years ago i couldn't believe i was broke
i was like i can try the glasses on for
free without leaving my house perfect
did it ended up falling in love got to
bought two of them and ever since then
like every year i buy a new pair of
warbies because it like updates my look
yeah and it's not yeah you don't have to
i've i've so many times i've spent like
800 on glasses like to fit my face it's
very hard so for them to be so
affordable and have the wide
face option is really
tailor-made here for me you can try five
pairs of glasses at home for free at
warbyparker.com
tuesday you guys that's
warbyparker.com tuesday and you can try
five pairs of glasses at home for free
i'm telling you like if you want to be
looking cute for the holidays and just
spice up your look this is like one of
my biggest secrets santa baby it's
holiday season and you don't know what
to get as a gift or stocking stuffer
well today's sponsor manscaped has the
tools to guarantee you win this year's
stocking stuffer competition if you want
your stocking to get stuffed you need
manscape well it is actually such a good
stocking stuffer it's great it's kind of
funny and it's funny it fits like all
the names of everything is hilarious
it's like it really is good it's useful
i mean todd seriously wears the
underwear the manscaped underwear you
can get 20 off plus free shipping at
manscape.com with code
get 20 off plus free shipping at
manscaped.com with our code trash i i
definitely think this is like a great
just get the holiday shopping done get
the funny thing and also it's helpful
listen we all don't want to floss our
teeth we're not trying to be coughing up
hairs all the time ladies but we still
want to be a ho ho ho for the holidays
so we need to give guys the best gift
ever and that's manscaped manscaped
best-selling product is the performance
package 4.0 which is at the top of every
man's wishlist this year and inside
you'll find their lawnmower body trimmer
which i use the best trimmer on the
market for his you know
or her back
the list goes on and the weed whacker
ear and nose hair trimmer so make sure
you hurry to their site to ensure these
wild gifts show up before the holiday
season and while you're at it get 20 off
plus free shipping at manscaped.com
with the code trash and whether it's for
your partner esther's dad brother friend
get them something that they could
actually and will use and
maybe they'll laugh hopefully they laugh
get 20 off and free shipping at
manscape.com with code trash
cheers to rocking the best gifts of all
this season a gift for him but it's
really a gift for you
xoxo mansky
can i tell you something esther that
really this is this is speaking to me at
the moment because yesterday i watched
an episode of antique rojo bobby knight
that's like a favorite show
lovely watching the highest thing that
was ever up raised on that show that
like made the
like everyone in the room like pass out
was a oyster
um rolex from the 1970s
and it was worth upwards almost a
million dollars
so if you want to go heist this thing
i'm down
i'm in sign me up i just want to know
can i ask her
yeah yeah
my dad told me not to ask for the watch
he just said that's not right he just
got weird no but i'm like because he
didn't give it to her because he lost it
in vegas like it's
i think annie's right i think maybe
there's a reason why you don't think
it's it's there i just can't conceive
i just can't conceive someone just
pushing a rolex over and saying i can't
conceive either
that damn vaccine
annie
[Laughter]
esther but yeah i don't know i just
here's the thing it really scares me to
the thought of asking for it but i'm
it's definitely the two themes i'm
seeing okay because i'm trying to eagle
eagle view yes thank you you okay
two things are one
how long are you gonna live your life
following the rules of your parents okay
you're grown up now so whatever your dad
says it doesn't matter also
there's no like what would be your fear
and
like are you afraid of the rejection are
you afraid to listen
yeah tacky
your dad's not going to unlove you for
asking no i'm not concerned about my dad
i just thought it was interesting that
he said no but tacky is i feel like a
vibration it's your brand tacky's my
show i don't you i'm couldn't be happier
with the town yeah and you're you're
also reminding me that like i have a
total like life policy of like no
embarrassment nothing should ever
embarrass me so it's like what do i have
to lose
exactly
i just call this
long-lost ant up and be like hey isn't
it funny that we get like we could even
be possibly embarrassed and with our
stupid jobs
yeah like it's like my like
a thermometer was put in my ass on
camera yeah and it's your but you're
afraid to ask an old lady for a watch
yeah
because if she says no you just go like
okay and it just doesn't change your
life at all and she says yes you have a
sweet watch
but also maybe she can give it how old
is this woman that has it she's older
right she's like probably a little
younger than my dad but yeah so maybe
you just say can you just leave it to me
well she has a daughter and a son but
it's but she should leave it to you why
don't you because that's a better angle
rather than
oh i'm going for bank heights but then
you do you are reaching this distant
cousin or this distant honor whatever
she is and you're going hey you're going
to die soon when you die soon can i have
that rolex it's really shitty but the
thing is i don't even want it because
it's a rolex you like i want to make one
sentimental what if she said esther
i'm not going to give you the rolex but
i'm going to give you in cash what it's
worth i don't want that at all i'll see
you okay [ __ ] no i don't want i have no
interest in anyone else's money at all
you guys i work on trash tuesday i'm
doing um dave did you hear her we know
what he's been mad about now and i would
actually even if she was like oh i have
this thing that's costume julian it's
fake that was hers i would take that
it's not about that there is something
about having because it's your
it really is it's your lineage it's your
history their dna is in you i'm her only
grandchild that ever existed i never met
her she like i have her name
i lived in her i was raised in her home
like i have nothing but so your dad gave
it to her before you were born or were
you already born
uh but no before i was because that
would be so funny just be like the day i
was born he's just like reaching over
you to give it to me the day i was born
he looks and he's like not cute enough
which actually is a real thing is there
any other stuff that he gave out that
you could ask he just doesn't
he doesn't know like my mom told me like
all those ants have like since passed
away and like they have their own
relative like there's no way to trace it
basically i would be knocking them down
i would have a chart with their faces
and each one that passes away i would
just put a cross over it and then ask my
dad what asks you're supposed to do it
before you kill them you cross them out
before you go i'm coming for you but i
cavorkian them all this talk does make
me go back to something that annie that
you say a lot it's like
what it's not gonna solve my problems
it's not gonna like i'm not gonna meet
her like if i get her watch but
like so i know that i know those things
logically right are you good at keeping
memorabilia are you good at keeping
things safe and clean and in an
appropriate place i think a little bit
would you lose it in a move
this no
like if i thought it was the delicate
delegator
the grim groomer like i'd probably
carlos would know where this would be
hidden oh my god
carlos would get a rolex
all this is is carlos ends up again with
a [ __ ] women's big seven with
something that's really expensive that
is belongs to another woman wait is
carlos coming with us to hawaii yeah
oh poor todd that's his hang on
todd was like wait dave's not going
because dave and todd would literally
love each other i know
i know
i have one request for hawaii
i want to eat
or see
i want a really really tasty pineapple a
fresh pineapple people go to the dole
plantation can we is that like cheesy to
do it's cheesy okay but that's no
there's pineapples everywhere
cause like in my hometown there's this
restaurant called blind faith cafe and
they have this smoothie called the
hawaiian sunrise and like on winter days
i would always get it and like fantasize
that i was in hawaii so i want to just
like
i want to have that the real experience
i watched my friend i drink a smoothie
and i fantasize you're in hawaii
i go how do we get her
out of here
i watched my friend rob break up with a
girl right in front of me because she
didn't know how pineapples grow
we were at a we're at a party at my
house color me that girl because i can't
even imagine it i can't even imagine you
guys tell me how you think pineapples a
tree
[Laughter]
they're grown palm trees
with coconuts
yes they're your answer
i think they come out of the ground i
honestly don't know
wait pineapple pineapple it must be
randy pine
i like how she's trying to figure it out
an apple comes from a tree pine cone
comes from
a tree
okay so if you put them together it
cancels it out it's not a tree
there is some algebra
this girl had such big boobs and she was
beautiful and she was a flight attendant
and he just straight ended it with her
when she was like do pineapples grow on
trees he was like can you leave i had a
boyfriend who said that he had a dream
that
um
that that i was on an elevator with him
or something and someone else came on
and i was really dumb
i was like what and he was like yeah you
were like really you couldn't like
answer any questions
that were like quizzing you on american
history and you couldn't answer any
questions and i was like
i was like oh that's kind of feels like
you think i'm dumb
here's what the pandemic really f [ __ ]
for me is like these old school mom and
pop shops
that i thought were going to be around
forever that i took for granted
i would kiss you if i was closer look at
her
look at her her eyeshadow matches i mean
honestly you guys we have to admit we're
all pretty-ish yeah
but
but you know i don't want to do you
remember um beverly soon tofu yeah i
really stopped listening to what she was
saying it was just like
a vision in her [ __ ] mushroom shirt
oh yes i thought you would like that i
love it what is it how what tell us um
it's a men's brand and i just saw this
shirt that uh god what the [ __ ] is the
name i forget
but doesn't it look like a random
vintage will you text me the info for
just so i know i just want to i want to
know more it's my most favorite sweater
recently wait
is it banana break time
[Music]
i want to manifest a plan
because i was just thinking there is
still a jewish deli in
the chicagoland area that's really good
called max and benny's mm-hmm
are you taking us home what if we went
on a skokie trip i would like and you
guys gotta dude we go to each other's oh
my god look at the [ __ ] philippines
you guys let's take each other home
i'll take you i'll i will take look at
randy right now
but also you know why this makes me so
happy yesterday because for years i've
been friends jenna has been my sister
for years and i'm like please take me
home please take me to chicago
your way
to chicago that you grew up 10 minutes
from each other but in completely
different neighborhoods she would never
have been seen with you in high school
and she was like yeah yeah yeah we'll go
home and then she never goes home
i know i shouldn't go home home but i'm
like take me to the places that you love
like that i'm like take me to kevin
bacon's ranch because that looks so fun
i love sosi by the way we really have
bonded over the challenge
and there's lots of dms non-stop
and sosi is one of us like she will
straight up send a picture of her labia
to you look at who her best friend is
it's jenna of course speaking of sending
pictures of labia um
esther do you do panoramic when you take
a picture of my husband
i need a i'm going to need a fish angle
for this one i got some sodas for you
guys
i hate soda don't tell us what it is
don't tell me the week i miss i hate
soda why are they in cups like because
they don't want us to see okay this is
where i'm going to shine because it's
not look at him look at him look at him
i'm going to make a chaser so this
segment is we're guessing the flavor
can someone give me alcohol okay so
based on looks looks like we got one is
green apple and one is like cherry but
i'm sure it's [ __ ] no what does it
smell like it's gonna be like spicy and
booger oh my god this smell is so
[ __ ] bad
she told me to
drink it it's like half syrup because
i'll look at her she's kind of horny
cough syrup
pete what the [ __ ]
come on this might be my weakness is
liquid oh oh my god i'm not supposed
first
i'm not smelling it first do it you go
i talked such a big game because it was
soda and it's so nasty tastes good
i'm trying it
they're both trying the brown one
it's brown i thought it was red i don't
like the way you said brown i can't see
it oh my god i'm gagging no you're
making this up esther it's not bad
esther what are you thinking
back into the cup esther esther
esther esther something to spit in
what okay wait we're doing the red one
it's so [ __ ] bad it's so what is
going on okay i'll go it might
have the same taste buds it's like
everything's fine we both have coven
let's be real yeah i don't taste
anything we've been eating each other's
[ __ ] all week we've just been we've
been just um equally transferring coven
back and forth okay here we go oh that's
this all tastes great are you guys
serious yes esther you're so full of
[ __ ] it's not good i'm not full of [ __ ]
at all it's really great is it like um
it tastes like apple
no it doesn't it tastes like [ __ ]
honestly like
feces i'll finish them it's like a
like a rotten vanilla thing like a
rotten i wouldn't like choosing it
tastes like trash it tastes like rotting
trash yeah that's my guess of the flavor
okay
rotting trash i don't know you could eat
yourself out
i don't know what random trash tastes
like
can i tell you that sometimes like every
three months i'll be like
something is rotten around here
listen we've all caught a self-whiff
okay here we go the green what's the
green
oh she totally is faking it
i don't i hate soda but this is like
what's so detailed it's all [ __ ]
i finished it guys more
no i don't really want more more daddy
i'm sure they love that sound i just
made
is that gonna be on your hinge profile
oh yeah
this is how i suck dick
if you were to put a voice note on your
hands right now what would you say
this is what it sounds like when i suck
dick
wait say that again one just one
sentence a voice of uh on your bio it's
a little voice note i'm half jewish have
regular my first joke i ever wrote
i thought you said the first joke you
say every time you've been on stage ever
since i met you
i'd say i know joe rogan
[Laughter]
i don't know what i would say and that's
actually really hard it feels like a
full career trying to figure out how to
like sandwiches
everyone it's like how do i let them
know without
being you know like you want to drop the
name but you got to find like an
opportunity to drop it i think bios are
so high pressure that's where i fail
like i don't put a bio away files but we
should probably guess okay i'm guessing
that the red one is i said riding trash
what is it pete dirt soda that the brown
one is dirt soda but here's the thing
they had still have to make it taste
good enough for people to drink no they
didn't that's what you're you're wrong
about that i think annie's right no
it does not taste like dirt at all
why does it have no ingredients okay
that's a concern oh wait okay
carbonated artist artesian spring water
cane sugar okay you're right artificial
flavor
ester gum
wow that's why it tastes like rotten
trash i told you
esther gum i've never seen that on a
label speaking of esther gum how is your
discharge
you want me to
do you want me to check your discharge
in 16 candles you saw that right you
probably didn't no see the [ __ ] most
classic amazing we should really do a
move-a-thon with her moveathon
that's so like by the way the classic
signs of like early in a relationship
when you're like
i want you to see all the movies that i
like like like i'm finally warming up to
you after 12 years i'm like you know
what i like the kid what are you what
are you watching on the second date
maybe i will go on a second date with
this one
it's been a long first date whoo first
five movies you want to watch with him
uh for a date uh-huh psycho sunset
boulevard oh god
she's mentally ill in the future
she's mentally ill folks annie what's
yours 12 years a slave 12 years a slave
hotel rwanda
and i love hotel rwanda that movie the
hills have eyes i want to see how they
react to me ptsd twitching during the
rape scene
i mean there's nothing scarier than that
i'm literally todd turn it off like todd
i wake up and todd is just watching the
most like gruesome i'm like just not
rapes i can have anything else but it
could be a light implied rape scene i
don't want to watch it's like what is
this a home video from my childhood mind
and probably
might probably have to be old boy okay
um being there
and then um drop dead fred oh i've never
seen those do you remember drinking fred
annie yeah
fred um what about bob i haven't seen in
a while though i used to watch it over
and over again yeah
um i don't know remember that movie dave
with the two presidents oh yeah that was
a fun one
[Music]
but wait what was ew
can you catch halitosis
that's so cute i talked about when
whitney like put his head in her mouth
his head in her mouth and then he had
just eaten his own he had eaten so much
of his own [ __ ] todd and i were like
and then we told her months later
thinking like
the she didn't the time when she and she
was very like oh oh she was yeah it was
i don't think she wouldn't care wait
what was i gonna say before what was the
movie i brought up oh 16 candles
when uh molly ringwald gives her
underwear to the kid what's his name
michael um
yeah she gives her underwear to this guy
and i'm like in what universe are there
not just snail trail crusty yeah like i
would never give my like crusty
underwear so crusty i've never been like
like i've never been like oh are these
cleaner dirty like i've there's never
been like a question
do you sign a side b
never no
i did that i don't either no i used to
do that when i was younger when you were
younger right yeah i mean like when i
was spent the summer in new york i
changed she was just in new york last
week guys this is what she was talking
about
no i was like 19 and i always turned my
underwear inside out and i washed them
and 19 is not that young esther i was
thinking more along the lines of like
eight years old
really yeah remember when you were a kid
didn't you like the smell of your
underwear when you were kid i still
smell my underwear today i like knowing
where i'm at it takes that turn like it
can be like a good bad smell and then it
takes that turmeric it got spicy i i
know when it gets spicy spicy i know now
exactly when it gets spicy if i'm having
a very anxious day stressful if like
something in my life is not working out
or if i'm around social situations i
feel high pressure
it's a spicy panty day is that like why
you're you're stinky now oh no
yesterday yeah
today i'm just hemorrhaging i've never
had a period this strong in my life
really
oh my god i i bled through not just for
underwear yesterday
three sweatpants
what like as soon as i put a tampon in i
stood up and it bled through i've never
cause i always have light periods but um
yeah so you [ __ ] i know i have the
lightest periods i have sex throughout
my life i don't even know i forget i get
my period until i stand up and look at
the furniture and go
like i don't even like acknowledge it
periods and then it's like well now i
guess since this podcast because i
really have a rage
attack once every two recordings i'm
like oh i guess one time a guy that i
was dating like the first time i slept
at his place
i woke up and
i had got my period on his bed and i for
a split second i was like i could just
tell him that i was a virgin
yeah no it's there's never been
a mattress or nothing's ever escaped
my crimson
wait let's just say my crimson wave is a
tsunami
that's a that's a movie right crimson
tide crimson tide about annie's period
it's about my period it's a horror film
my mom esther gets killed in it wait my
mom almost died of red tide what does
that mean um when there are a lot of
toxins accumulated well toxins in a fish
it's if you come from like a fish faring
nation
um
a seafaring nation seafaring nation we
have a lot of fishermen red tide is when
there's an algal bloom there's an algae
bloom and um the fish sort of um have
these toxins accumulate in their body
and then you end up eating that fish and
then you get the tacos you get the red
yeah you get the toxins but should we
have we were around a family lunch and
she ate the fish first and then all of a
sudden you could see her not feeling
well and my dad like pouring sugar in
her mouth for some reason and then
taking her to the hospital but it was
really scary the [ __ ] out of me when i
was young it's very scary to see your
mom faint i know she's not she's not
someone you could ever yeah because my
mom's like sturdy she doesn't have abs
but she's like a sturdy strong yeah like
for my mom to ever like not be
to trip even right yes it's just very
weird to see my mom not just like
totally like
holding it down like
she's very sure-footed
things just my mom does twist her ankle
out actually one time she twisted her
ankle on the subway and instead of
helping her a guy shut her shoulders
wait that's similar to how my sister did
a double ankle sprain
we were at my friend's party in in
koreatown and she walked up to the
bedroom she wasn't supposed to walk up
to because there it was like a house
party and apparently his korean mom was
full on like fisting herself oh my god
and she was like oh i'm so sorry and
then she tried to go down the stairs and
she did it too fast and she twisted both
of her ankles and then slid down the
gotta get out of stairs
for six months
for six months she couldn't walk
properly but it's the same thing it's
like i think you have to see something
so
horribly sexual for you to break both
angles
hey wait you know what i was thinking
i'm thinking about all these like
ex-boyfriend talks do you know who i am
still friends with guys i never [ __ ]
but i
like kissed when i was young i'm still
friends with them yeah because it's
there's something about if we banged i
can't yeah that makes sense i feel like
that's a very healthy thing you do where
you're like you're out you're out but i
never used to be like that i used to
cling to them i would call them when i
was feeling down and needed some sort of
pep talk you've grown yeah you've grown
up and you have a good partner yeah i do
so
and podcasting yeah
you're like and you have a really good
friend right here
i yeah no i but i was thinking about
that because my friend nick i just was
thinking about him
and i can't remember what were we just
talking about why was i thinking about
him double sprain um
oh i broke my foot in the virgin islands
did i tell you the story my mom sent me
so i was like kind of bad i wasn't like
fully bad yet but i was like well
actually i was way worse than i knew i
was like sneaking out hooking up with
like grown men
everyone had weapons that i was hanging
out with
i they just philadelphia if you cross
the border
and you go into a certain area you are
just
and we were just like dating gang
members all of a sudden we were 14 but
anyway
so my mom i was like acting up my mom
and i were fighting a lot i had this
cousin that's i don't even know how she
was anyone's cousin but she was like a
little older than my mom
and she lived in the virgin islands and
she was like i'll take annie for the
summer why don't you send her for like
three weeks and she can come hang out
with me and i was like 14. i was like
[ __ ] yeah i'm going to the [ __ ]
virgin islands so i went to saint croix
and i stayed with her she kicked me out
within three i think i was like four
days
[ __ ] out of here
but in that four days i got wasted i met
my friend nick i can't remember how i
met him
um but i met him and then i fell down
the stairs drunk and i had a broken foot
and nick just carried me on his back the
entire time and he would go climb and
get me coconuts and stuff from the tree
it was fun to go to the rain forest but
the whole point is
um i broke my foot
and you're still friends with nick and i
love nick he's great he's gonna design
my um the set for the annie letterman
show so i'm bringing it up on here um
i'm cheating i have to run friends and
family
for once i actually wanted to be the one
i have to take my car in because someone
swiped why does this always happen it
was like when you get something new
someone swiped my always the back of my
car was it in your driveway in one of us
we don't know it could be i'm checking
my cameras it's probably by now bobby
definitely did it
guys we had a lot of fun today um we
never wanted to end but at last i have
to go to the car dealership because
someone swiped my car and it was
definitely bobby and her own the
taillight is broken there's no way it
wasn't bobby i'm checking the cameras
because i think it's one of you too
um
thank you so much for watching this
week's episode of trash tuesday formerly
known as bb as oh we're getting it back
don't forget to like this video and
comment for the algorithm and uh follow
us on instagram all the things
see you next week also just one more
thing what do you guys think truly about
the name hot holes what about when the
guy said three sixes when he said three
sixes three sixes is pretty funny
because it's like the devil but i'm
forever hanging on to skull [ __ ] the
faith-based podcast it's honestly
heading more in that direction than i
ever thought it would good
speaking of head goodbye bye guys i'm
off to suck a dick bye we gotta go blow
blow
[Music]
you